Ich bin bereit.
Sehr schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Toprak. Ich bin Rüsten, Gastenarzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmen sprechen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, sehr schön.
Bevor Sie in der aktuellen Beschwerden kommen, muss ich noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen hier darstellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Berger.
Können Sie Ihren Namen langsam und deutlich vorstellen, Herr Thomas?
Mein Name ist Berger.
Baby Bertha, Baby Emil, Baby Richard, Baby Gustav, Baby Emil, Baby Richard.
Mein Vorname ist Thomas T. V. Theodor, Harvey Heinrich, O. V. Otto, M. V. Martha, A. V. Anton und S. V. Siegfried.
Vielen Dank. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Berger?
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
65 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 7. Februar 1961.
61.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß und wiege 92 Kilogramm.
Wie viel?
92.
Haben Sie ungewollte Abholung genommen?
Nein.
Sie wiege aktuell 92 Kilogramm.
92, genau.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich komme zu Ihnen, weil ich seit der Nacht oder seit dem Abend starke Herzrhythmusstörungen habe.
Könnten Sie Ihre Beschwerden genau beschreiben?
Ich habe ein starkes Herzklopfen und einen unregelmäßigen Herzschlag.
Herzklopfen und unregelmäßigen? Was meinen Sie?
Ein unregelmäßiger Herzschlag.
Ist diese Beschwerden erstmals aufgetreten?
Ich habe das gestern Abend.
Bevor gestern?
Ich habe das noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen?
Ich habe keine Brustschmerzen.
Oder enge Gefühle?
Nein.
Und?
Ich habe gemerkt, als ich gestern Abend die Treppen hochgestiegen bin zu meinem Schlafzimmer, habe ich wirklich Luftnot gehabt.
Seit gestern Abend?
Seit gestern Abend.
Leidet Sie Atemnot?
Bevor gestern hatten Sie auch keine Beschwerden.
Nur bei Belastungen oder?
Das habe ich gemerkt, ja.
Ich habe zusätzlich ein wenig Schwindel und innere Unruhe.
Innere Unruhe, ok.
Haben Sie auch Temperaturempfindlichkeit?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ihr meint, dass eine hohe Temperatur stört sich so viel?
Nein?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Sind Sie schwindelig gerade?
Ich habe ab und zu Schwindel. Aktuell nicht.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Schwindel?
Seit gestern Abend.
Leiden Sie auch unter die unruhige Gefühle?
Genau.
Seit wann haben Sie auch unruhige Gefühle?
Seit gestern Abend.
Haben Sie tolles Angst?
Nein.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser, die die Beschwerden und Schwindelmethode verlindern?
Wenn ich mich belaste.
Haben Sie auch die Herzschlupfen in Ruhe oder nicht?
Ja.
Ich konnte die Nacht nicht gut schlafen.
Leiden Sie unter Schlafstörungen?
Ja.
Haben Sie auch Schlafstörungen?
Ich habe die Nacht nicht gut geschlafen.
Seit gestern, ja?
Seit gestern.
Ein Schlafen oder ein Durchschlafen?
Beides.
Ist Ihnen eine Haare aus aufgefallen?
Vorher?
Ich meine das von Ihrer Haare.
Seit gestern oder vorher schon?
Vorher. Ich meine innerhalb einer Monat.
Eine Monat.
Fühlen Sie sich schwach?
Normal.
Haben Sie gerade Leistungminderung?
Ja.
Fühlen Sie sich schläfig gerade?
Nein.
Hatten Sie früher Herzerkrankungen festgestellt?
Bitte?
Hatten Sie früher eine Herzerkrankung?
Ich habe nur Bluthochdür.
Nur Bluthochdür.
Haben Sie leiden Sie die Zittern die Hand handeln?
Leiden Sie unter die Zittern?
Nein. Aber keine Zittern die Handeln.
Haben Sie eine Zäure in Orch?
Zäure?
Ja. Zäure in Orch.
Hören Sie etwas unterschiedlich?
Nein.
Haben Sie Hörstörung?
Oder Selbststörung?
Nein.
Waren Sie schon einmal ohnmächtig?
Hatten Sie auch andere Probleme?
Nein.
Ist bei Ihnen eine Schilddrüse unter Funktionen?
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen vorhanden Kunden oder Openspekant außer Arterie Bluthochdür?
Ja. Ich habe noch Cholesterinerhöhung.
Seit wann?
Das habe ich schon länger, seit fast 15 Jahren.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seitdem ich ungefähr 49 oder 50 bin.
Messen Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig ein?
Ja. Einmal die Woche.
Ist die Blut eingestellt oder nicht?
Momentan ja.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ich wurde einmal am Ohr operiert, als ich noch jung war.
Der Blinddarm ist raus.
Ich hatte vor 30 Jahren eine Schulteroperation.
Schulter?
Ja.
Was war das? Eine Verletzung?
Eine Verletzung. Okay.
Bantrisen? Sie meinen das?
Ja. Das ist schon lange her. Fast 30 Jahre jetzt.
Fast 30 Jahre. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja. Ich nehme RamiPril ein.
Morgens 10 Milligramm.
Und ich nehme Atobastatin 40 Milligramm abends einmal ein.
40 Milligramm abends, ja?
Genau.
Und was noch?
10 Milligramm.
Ja. Und ich nehme Atobastatin.
Genau.
Und ich nehme nur die beiden.
Brauchen Sie Herberger?
Nein. Ich habe aufgehört.
Wann haben Sie aufgehört?
Vor 5 Jahren.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ja. Fast 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre.
Wie viele Schachteln oder wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht innerhalb dieses 40 Jahren?
Eine Schachtel ungefähr. Ich habe ungefähr 20 bis 25 Tabletten geraucht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Nein. Gar nicht.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine routinische Frage.
Ich soll diese jede Patientefrage stellen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Das ist eine Rassungsmischung.
Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergie und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nur gegen Hausstoff.
Wie reagiert Hausstoff darauf?
Mit Kaum und Jucken, Niesen.
Jucken, Niesen.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie Medikamente?
So selten. Eigentlich gar nicht.
Gibt es wichtige Familienerkrankungen, die ich wissen soll?
Mein Vater ist an einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Er war 68 Jahre alt.
Und meine Mutter hatte Bluthochdruck.
68 Jahre?
Er war 68 Jahre alt. Ganz genau.
Im Alter war er 68 Jahre alt.
Genau.
Schlaganfall? Verstorben. Okay.
Und meine Mutter?
Sie hatte Bluthochdruck.
Sie ist aber an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Seit wann? Im ganzen Alter?
Sie war ungefähr 86 Jahre alt. Oder 87.
87.
87. Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine ältere Schwester.
Wie ist Ihr Gesundheitsstand?
Sie ist gesund.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Herr Thomas?
Ich bin verheiratet. Mein Name ist Bergham.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Ich habe zwei Töchter.
Die beiden sind gesund?
Beide sind gesund, ja.
Waren Sie im letzten sechs Monate im Ausland?
Ich war in Spanien gewesen. Vor drei Monaten.
Ist Ihnen ein Hausaufschlag aufgefallen?
Nein.
Waren Sie in Spanien im Natur?
Ich bin immer am Pool.
Wie war das?
Am Schwimmbad.
Am Schwimmbad?
Wann waren Sie in Spanien?
Vor drei Monaten war ich in Spanien.
Vor drei Monaten.
Aber Sie waren nicht im Wald oder im Natur?
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ich war nicht im Wald, ich war nicht im Natur.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja. Ich habe mein Haus auskontrolliert.
Okay.
Was machen Sie normalerweise?
Ich bin Rennner.
In welchem Bereich haben Sie früher gearbeitet?
Ich bin Architekt.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren und fahre Fahrrad.
Im Wald oder im Natur?
Im Wald, auf der Straße.
Okay. Wenn Sie im Natur wollten, verwenden Sie eine Affeermittel gegen Insekten oder nicht?
Nein.
Nein? Keine Affeermittel, ja?
Okay. Danke.
Eigentlich habe ich meinerseits eine wichtige Frage gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein. Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Ja, ich denke mal, ich kann nicht genau sagen, aber ich habe Verdacht auf eine Herz-Ethnistörung.
Eine neue anfangende Herz-Ethnistörung.
Ich muss zuerst eine EKG verschreiben.
Schreiben.
Schreiben. EKG schreiben.
Entschuldigung. Ja, Entschuldigung. Schreiben.
Danach eine Blutabnahme. Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, werde ich Ihnen informieren.
Alles klar. Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Ist Ihnen eine geschwollene Beine aufgefallen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Was machen Sie als Beruf?
Rennnach.
Ah ja.
Sind Sie blass?
Nein. So, dann machen wir ein Affenaufgespräch.
Ja, genau.
Vielen Dank. Haben Sie kurze Zeit? Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Sehr schön.
Thomas Berger ist 65 Jahre alt, geboren am 17.02.1961.
1,80 m groß und wiegt aktuell 92 kg.
Er stelle sich seit gestern mit der Gartekarte und der Rüttel vor.
Die Beschwerden seien erstmals aufgetreten.
Seit gestern Abend hat er Düsse und leider eine Schwindeligkeit.
Er hat aktuell Durche und eine Schlafstörung.
Seit gestern hat er Düsse bei einer Belastung.
Die Frage nach Blass, Zitterende Hand, Leistungminderung wurden vermeint.
Als Vorerkaukung hat er Arteriellehypertönis seit 10 Jahren.
Er nehme regelmäßig Ramiprin, 10 mg morgens.
Seit 5 Jahren hat er Hyperkolostrinemie.
Er nehme gegen am Abend 40 mg Athorvastatin.
Als Kind war eine Or-Operation verursacht.
Er war in der Arthrose und war in der Arthrose.
Wegen der Verletzung musste er schuld und bantris operieren.
Er hat vor 5 Jahren das Rauchen aufgehört.
Er ist extra hoch, ca. 5 Jahre.
Die Droge wurde vermeint.
Er hat eine Hautstaballergie, reagiert darauf auf Leukreis, Pyrrhorytes und Nissen.
In der Familiengeschichte ist der Vater im Alter von 68 Jahren an Inzut verstorben.
Die Mutter ist im Alter von 87 Jahren an Myokartinfarkt verstorben.
Er hat eine gesunde Geschwister.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Tochter.
Früher hat er als Architektin gearbeitet.
Er war vor drei Monaten in Spanien.
Der Impfungsstatus war unaufwendig.
Was haben Sie für eine Verdachtstheratose?
Aufgrund der anemestischen Angabe und der Geschildertenbeschwerden habe ich eine Verdacht auf eine Herzrhythmusstörung, eine Dysarritmik oder eine Tachikardin.
Die Diagnose ist in Anämie oder Herzinstitutionen in Betracht.
Welche Diagnose würden Sie für eine Verdachtstheratose stellen?
Herzinstitution, die Stürmer, die Kanzlein, Paroxysin.
Das kann auch eine BG-- oder eine Tachikardin sein.
Was ist die beinahe Diagnose im Alter?
Atrialfibriation, Vorhoffnismen.
Wahrscheinlich, aber Sie haben recht. Es kann auch alles andere sein.
Es kann auch eine Venterikuläre extra-systole sein.
Das sehen wir erst im EKG.
Die EG- ist aber hier von einem Vorhoffnismen aus.
Warum sagen Sie das erste Mal Vorhoffnismen? Wegen des Altes?
Wie bitte?
Warum gehen Sie zuerst die Vorhoffnismen-Diagnose?
Weil das die meistgestellte Diagnose ist im Alter.
Wegen des Altes, ok.
Ich habe es vergessen, aber genau richtig.
Atrialfibriation.
Ja, so weiter.
So weiter Abklärung.
Und so wie Ausfluss von der Differenzial-Diagnose,
werde ich zuerst natürlich den EKG schreiben.
Und einen ganzen täglichen EKG. Ambulant-EKG.
Wie heißt das? Ich weiß nicht. Eine tagliche EKG.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Wie heißt die 24-sachliche EKG?
Wie bitte?
Die 24-sachliche EKG.
Langzeit-EKG.
Aber das machen Sie nicht in der Ambulanz.
Das machen Sie stationär.
Nicht in der Ambulanz. Was machen Sie in der Notaufnahme?
Ja, genau.
Was machen Sie da?
Die 24-sachliche EKG.
Die Herz-Ensüme.
Natürlich wichtig ist die Herz-Ensüme.
Blutbild, Großblutbild, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte.
Und Prokrastonin-Ni.
Pro-BNP.
Und ein Wert noch. Ganz wichtig.
Ganz wichtig.
Gehen wir noch ein paar Meter?
Schilddrüsenwerte.
Schilddrüsenwerte, ja genau.
Ganz wichtig, ja?
Warum ist das wichtig?
Die Hyperträume kann auf die Ursprache gesetzt werden.
Ganz genau. Richtig.
Genau so ist es.
Ja, genau.
Ok, Sie machen eine EKG und Sie sehen, es ist vorflimmern.
Er hat eine absoluten Tachyarrhythmie bei Vorflimmern.
Was machen Sie?
Wir müssen sofort einleiten.
Was ist vorher?
Vorher war es eine niedrige molekylare Heparin.
Nein.
Was heißt das?
Wir müssen die Überbrüche auf die Ekokardiopatien machen.
Auch im Verlauf. Richtig.
Wir haben eine sehr schnelle Herzfrequenz.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir müssen die Herzfrequenz mit der Antihalitmus brechen.
Nein.
Sie müssen erst die Frequenz senken.
Ja, ok, betablockieren.
Genau, richtig.
Wir müssen die Betablockierung.
Genau, Sie machen eine Betablockertherapie, eine Frequenzlimitierung oder Senkung.
Ja, ja.
Damit es den Patienten besser geht.
Alles aber unter Monitorüberwachung.
Der Patient muss an den Monitor.
Ja, an den Monitor überwacht.
Ja, genau.
Dann können Sie von mir aus Ultraschall machen, von mir aus Herzecho machen.
Das ist alles ok.
Sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf?
Muss, ja genau.
Weil die Thrombose oder Emboli kann von der Vorfallflimme in die Cirkulation einlegen.
Und verursacht die Verstopfung.
Verursacht die Verstopfung, ja.
Er hat gesagt, er hat das seit gestern Abend.
Es sind keine 24 Stunden vergangen.
Ja, genau.
Also, dass ein Thrombus nicht bildet, ist sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Aber, aber, vielleicht hat er das vor mehreren Monaten schon mal gehabt und er hat es nicht bemerkt.
Ja.
Deswegen ist es immer sinnvoll, den Patienten einen Herzultraschall zu machen und auch eine orale Antikoagulation zu geben.
Das können Sie machen mit Xarelto, Elipvis, Lixiana.
Makuma macht man nicht mehr.
Makuma ist nicht mehr so Standard.
Ok.
Gut. Ok.
Dann nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf.
Die sind in der Verkaufung, im Blut ist alles in Ordnung.
Blutbild ist gut, Elektrolyte ist gut, Natrium, Kalium ist gut, Schildpryse ist gut, ProBNP ist in Ordnung.
Ein bisschen erhöht vielleicht, Tropolin minimal erhöht, weil Herzrasen hat.
Was machen Sie dann?
Sie machen einen Ultraschall, aber was für einen Ultraschall machen Sie?
Transfagial Ultraschall ist besser.
Die Transfagial Ultraschall ist besser, die hinten besser sehen.
Genau, man kann sehen, ob im linken Vorhochohr ein Thrombus ist oder nicht.
Die Thrombose besser, besser.
Kann man besser eruieren, genau.
Und wenn Sie das gemacht haben, was machen Sie als nächstes?
Als nächstes Schritt.
Eine elektrische Kardiobversion.
Ja, wir machen eine elektrische Kardiobversion, falls der Patient nicht selber in den Sinusrhythmus konvertiert.
Okay.
Elektrische Kardiobversion.
Brauchen wir auch die Elektrofysiologie, die Unterzucht und Intervention in diesen Patienten?
Also muss man das nicht unbedingt machen, weil das das erste Mal ist.
Okay.
Die Frage ist jetzt, was machen Sie weiter? Machen Sie sonst irgendwas?
Machen Sie eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung oder machen Sie das nicht oder sagen Sie, das kann man später machen?
Ja, Herzkatheteruntersuchung.
Eigentlich nein.
Nein, braucht man nicht, aber sollte man im Verlauf machen. Warum?
Man will wissen, warum er diese Vorflümmern hat und im Alter, in seinem Alter könnte eine K.H.K. ein Grund für ein Vorflümmern sein.
Genau, Sie meinen, dass die Chemische Bereiche die Extrasysteme haben können.
Genau.
Chemische Vorkunft und alle Herzkatheter.
Also müssen Sie oder welche Medikamente schreiben Sie den Patienten jetzt auf und können ihn nach zwei Tagen nach Hause entlassen?
Welche Medikamente würden Sie aufschreiben?
Medimonokulärepanen, Sie meinen das?
Nein.
Es gibt neue DOACs oder NOACs.
Ah, neue ORAL.
Neue Orale Antikoagulation.
Nevaroxaban, Endoxaban, Apixaban.
Das kann man aufschreiben. Die sind etwas besser als Marcomar. Warum?
Man kann die besser steuern.
Man kann besser steuern.
Müssen Sie dem Patienten jetzt auf Dauer eine ORAL Antikoagulation geben? Ja oder nein?
Ja.
Warum?
Eine ORAL Antikoagulation ist nicht eine dauerhafte...
Nein, nicht immer.
Er ist jetzt wieder am Sinusrhythmus.
Wie? Der kann normal sein?
Ja klar. Nach antikoagulation, nach elektrische Kovasion.
Hm, nach elektrische Kovasion kann normaler Verlauf sein. Okay.
Und das musst du das nicht entschuldigen.
Es gibt einen Score, wonach Sie entscheiden können, ob Sie weiter Antikoagulation machen müssen oder nicht.
Wie heißt dieser Score?
Ich weiß nicht eigentlich.
Chats-Basque-Score.
Was?
Schon mal gehört?
Nein, ich habe nicht gehört.
Dann müssen wir wissen.
Das ist mein erster Mal.
Wie das erste Mal?
Das ist jeder.
Das müssen Sie können.
Ja, ich werde lernen.
Das müssen Sie nachlesen.
Ja, ich werde nachlesen.
Es gibt noch einen Score.
Chats-Blitz-Score.
Schon mal gehört?
Nein, auch nicht.
Ich schreibe das in den Chat.
Chats-Blitz-Score.
Ja, dann...
Das müssen Sie nachlesen.
Genau.
Danach können Sie entscheiden, ob Sie die Antikoagulation fortführen müssen oder sagen können, ich lasse sein.
Okay?
Das müssen Sie einmal durchlesen bitte.
Ja, ich werde durchlesen.
Aber ich würde diesen Patienten aufgrund seines Alters, aufgrund seiner Hypertonie, die er hat, hat er zwei Punkte, würde ich ihm eine orale Antikoagulation empfehlen.
Warum?
Weil er einen Schlagaufschlaganfall gehabt hat.
In seiner...
Der ist ja gestorben.
Er ist auf Schlaganfall gefährdet.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig, genau.
Genau.
Ansonsten kann er seine Medikamerationen fortführen.
Ich würde ihm noch einen Better Blocker aufschreiben.
Vielleicht Bisoprolol oder Metropolol.
Und dann gucken wir weiter.
Irgendwann im Verlauf sollte auf jeden Fall eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung gemacht werden, um zu gucken, ob er eine K.A.K. hat oder nicht.
Eine Langzeitblutdruck bzw. EKG-Kontrolle sollte auch erfolgen.
Am besten stationär, im Verlauf auch ambulant durch den Hausarzt oder durch den niedergelassenen Kardiologen.
Mhm.
Haben Sie alles verstanden?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie alle verstanden?
Gibt es Fragen?
Ja.
Normalerweise hat es eine Langzeit-EKG einen besonderen Namen oder nicht?
Langzeit-EKG?
Langzeitblutdruck.
Gibt es Fragen?
Wenn nicht, können wir die Aufnahme beenden?